Madam president Secretary General
excellencies
my generation was raised with the idea
that our children and grandchildren
would be better off
than us
but a Cascade of crisis has now set back
progress towards our sustainable
development goals
first the pandemic
then Russia's war of aggression with its
devastating impact for Global Food and
energy security
all of this with the knock-on effects of
a boiling planet
against this backdrop
developing countries do need more
resources
to pull people out of poverty
and to transition towards a clean
and equal economy
and this is why I welcome the secretary
General's sdg stimulus plan
in 2022
Europe elevated its development Aid to
93 billion euros an increase of 30
percent
over the previous year
and today
we account for over 40 percent of the
global assistance
we know our obligations
but Public Funding alone is not enough
we must explore all avenues to attract
new funding
towards developing countries and first
and foremost there is the reform of the
mdbs without any question but let me
focus on two ways
in which we are answering the secretary
General's call
first we have to unlock private capital
with our global gateway investment plan
Europe is investing 300 billion euros in
developing economies in the next five
years
in renewable energy in stronger
Healthcare Systems in quality education
green transport and of course digital
Solutions
this is about equipping our partners
with the resources the Technologies and
the skills
to move up the value chain
to create jobs for their citizens and to
protect the environment
we're doing so by using a portion of our
public budget
to de-risk private Investments
and we're taking this further
we're also supporting developing an
emerging economies to create their own
green Bond markets
in order to attract even more fresh
capital
towards the sustainable development
goals
my second point is carbon pricing
carbon pricing is one of the most
efficient and effective climate policies
carbon pricing Fosters Innovation by the
private sector
it makes polluters pay a fair price on
carbon and their carbon emissions
while cutting emissions
and the revenues can support the clean
transition and developing countries let
me give you a few figures
last year alone Europe's carbon pricing
system raised 38 billion euros
and we are reinvesting 100 of it in
climate action
but if you look at the global greenhouse
gas emissions
only 20 percent are covered by carbon
pricing
now just imagine the global impact
in terms of new revenues while cutting
greenhouse gas emissions if more
countries adopted this strategy and
would introduce a carbon pricing and
dedicate a fair share of their revenues
to developing countries and Emerging
Markets
ladies and gentlemen
we must double down our efforts
and have the courage of Creative
Solutions
let's work together
to restore the promise that tomorrow
will be better than today for all people
on this planet thank you very much
students of the commission of the
European Union and I now give the floor
to its Excellency pushback Kamal dahal
prime minister of Nepal